Mattel's Barbie doll is an iconic figure
and a household name that many children
play with and many adults purchase as
collectable items although the Barbie
doll has been around since the 1950s
there's still so much about the doll
that is unknown if this is your first
time visiting her channel don't forget
to hit the subscribe button and give
this video a thumbs up because today
we're talking about all the amazing
facts you never knew about the Barbie
doll the first batch the first batch of
Barbie dolls were manufactured in Japan
in 1959 the very first doll was made of
heavy vinyl she came with honey blonde
or silky brunette hairstyle with bangs
and a ponytail and she was decked out in
a white and black zebra striped bathing
suit each bathing suit on every single
Barbie doll was carefully hand-stitched
pretty impressive right Barbie loves
fashion Barbie is definitely a
fashionista so to keep up with her
ever-changing style and her love for
clothing Mattel has used more than a
hundred and five million yards of fabric
to create Barbie and her friends outfits
the toy maker is now considered one of
the largest apparel manufacturers in the
entire world
when barbie isn't sporting her Mattel
designs she's wearing the outfits that
luxury fashion designers Gucci Dolce &
Gabbana and Versace have created for her
selling like hotcakes after being
released to stores in 1959 a total of
350 1000 Barbies were sold in that year
alone today the doll is still quite
popular and every second three Barbie
dolls are sold somewhere in the world if
you place every Barbie sold since 1959
head-to-toe they would circle around the
entire earth more than seven times
career woman Barbie is definitely a
career woman and a workaholic the doll
has had more than a hundred and thirty
different jobs including a surgeon a
firefighter and an astronaut
she even recently became a YouTube
blogger but out of all of her careers
she has dreams of becoming the first
woman president of the United States
Barbie has ran as a presidential
candidates six times since 1992
animal lover Barbie has a special place
in her heart for all animals she has had
over 40 different pets including a drop
a parrot a panda and over 20 dogs the
very first Barbie pet was a horse named
dancer which was released in 1971 the
horse came complete with a stand which
allowed it to rock back and forth a pair
of stirrups and a saddle her love life
Barbie and her boyfriend Ken have been
in a relationship since 1961 and
although they appear to be happy they
went through some pretty rough times in
the past in 2004 the couple announced
their breakup must to the dismay of
Barbie fans worldwide
but thankfully Barbie and Ken were able
to kiss and make up after reuniting on
the set of Toy Story 3 on Valentine's
Day 2013
Barbie confirmed the reconciliation by
changing her facebook status to in a
relationship humble beginnings Barbie's
real name is Barbara Millicent Roberts
and she was born on March 9th 1959
many people believe she's from Malibu
California but she actually originates
from the fictional town of Willow Woods
concen her parents are George and
Margaret Roberts and she has seven
siblings in total skipper Stacie Chelsea
Chrissy
Kelly Tootie and Todd the best-selling
Barbie although she was first released
in 1959 Fermi didn't reach her peak
until 1992 when Mattel debuted total
hair Barbie the doll had long and
flowing hair that reached down to her
ankles upon her release 10 million total
hair barbie dolls were sold she is still
considered to be the best-selling Barbie
that has ever been created
goodbye Dream House back in 1971 Barbie
purchased her sprawling bright pink
dream house in the city of Malibu Barbie
made so many wonderful memories in the
home but in 2013 Mattel announced the
doll would be putting her fictional
Malibu dream house up for sale the
property even received a listing on a
real estate website with a price tag of
25 million dollars quite a steal for an
85 hundred square feet home by the water
don't you think so what was the real
reason behind Barbie putting her dream
home up
for sale well Mattel was discontinuing
the house and creating a brand new
high-tech home for the doll named Barbie
hello dream house the most expensive
doll when Barbie was originally released
the doll sold for only $3 in stores
today the average Barbie doll will cost
you around $20 but if you're into the
collectible dolls those prices can be
astronomical the most expensive Barbie
doll ever made was created by a jewelry
designer named Stefano cantering
the doll which was draped in diamond
jewelry sold at an auction for three
hundred and two thousand dollars are you
a Barbie fanatic if so which one of
these facts were you most amazed by
leave us a comment down below and don't
forget to give this video a big big
thumbs up thanks for watching